Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
All right.
We did a bunch of stuff.
Now we're back from the zip code one.
Is that,
what was that about?
We took a break.
We had do stuff and then there's other stuff to do.
Okay.
All right.
Yeah,
I'm glad to be here.
I missed you.
I miss you.
You were gone.
You went to Fart next.
I did the second to last stop on this tour and then we're going to Hawaii
tomorrow hub.
I know.
What are you going to do on your vacay?
Take it easy.
Vape,
drink.
Just chill.
Are you going to be one of those dads?
It's at the bar at 10:00 AM when it opens.
Why shouldn't I be?
I'm celebrating the year.
The year's over.
That always amazes me.
Those people are like,
look,
everyone does their thing on vacation,
but that to me is like real endurance.
The people that like,
I'm just saying like a Bert Kreischer maybe you know at the bar when it opens
10:00 AM until Sunday
full day,
it's going to be a member.
Those dads and the Dominican Republic.
When we went there and they found out we had a porno channel and they were like,
what?
Yeah,
there so gels and they were eyeballing the,
uh,
the girl that was taken her photos.
Oh yeah.
Cute young girl.
And he was like,
check out.
Hey,
get over here.
Bob Cared.
They were like really dad and down on her.
So sad.
When you become a dad.
Yeah.
Do you feel sad yet?
Yeah,
of course.
Does that dad sadness open?
Oh yeah.
It's coming out of my pores.
What is the dad sadness about?
Just realize that funds over responsibility.
Yeah.
Now you got to like make sure everyone's okay and make sure lights are on food
in the house.
Just sad.
Yeah.
Mom's sadness is there too where you're like,
oh,
my body is destroyed and I have,
I worry constantly about else.
No more joy no more.
Yeah.
That's so true.
I mean,
I,
I don't think I really have fun deal.
Do we have fun?
Um,
no,
we don't have fun.
This might be like the most fun thing we do.
Yeah.
That's probably why we've kept it up for so long.
I'm sure it's why.
Yeah,
yeah.
We enjoy doing this.
Right,
but,
but in terms of scheduling,
fun and vacation is imperative.
You have to schedule The kid.
It doesn't matter where you're at in life.
I'm saying like if you go like,
oh,
vacations expensive.
If your vacation is just staying home,
not doing anything and driving to get ice cream at night and that's your base,
then that you need to do it.
You have to take a break.
Yeah,
take a break.
I think it's better to leave though.
It's always better to leave the home base because I've done the home vacay thing
too,
and then you just get wrapped up in your traditional drama.
It's true.
All right,
let's do a traditional,
oh yeah.
Wow.
Let's get into it.
Dual credit.
Dual credit card that I was taking a nap.
He had come home far did at me after.
I assume,
I just need to make sure I'm hearing this correctly.
Did you fart
her face?
Don't bring it to live
to your mom's house
and at Twitter.
That's all.
What?
What did you like?
Because I had,
I wrote a tweet it to that kid that got bullied.
Yeah.
And um,
I got the,
it got tweeted or retweeted a good bunch.
No,
I wrote,
um,
right,
right.
His name is Keaton if you haven't seen it,
there's this kid and he,
he makes this tells his mom that like kids are bullying me in school and it's
really,
he gets real emotional and he talks about how,
how it's the kids are so mean and he's like,
I don't understand.
What they do is when people are just different.
And she's like,
what do they say to you?
And he,
he tells her like they call me ugly and they're just really mean.
It's,
it's like a heartbreaking video.
And since she posted it went viral and like everyone is inviting this kid to
shit like Tennessee titans of bringing them to a football game.
Right.
I know celebrities are on,
but isn't that kind of bullying of the mother to post a very vulnerable,
it's a yellow sun isn't a while,
isn't that not protecting him?
Yeah,
I mean calling him.
Well anyways,
he is,
I see what you exactly what you're saying.
Do that.
I'd be like,
no,
don't fucking post that video.
You're an asshole for good.
It worked out in this way.
So he's got,
Cavaliers invited him to a game,
um,
three or four
movie stars have invited him to movie premieres,
Chris Evans,
uh,
what's his name?
Uh,
forget the fucking guys name.
Then Dana white invited them to a UFC headquarters.
So he's like,
everyone's reaching out this kid.
So I just stop for a second today and I wrote,
Hey Keaton,
don't get uh,
uh,
too,
too full of yourself with all this attention.
I will fuck you up.
And there's not a thing your mom or Lebron or Chris Evans can do about it.
And that's it.
It's funny.
Yeah.
And it get,
right now it's got about 3000 retweets and 8,000 likes.
But yeah,
both of the,
uh,
the comments underneath that are hilarious because people are either being like,
hell yes.
And getting that,
that's a joke.
Or,
and putting like funny memes and gifs under it or they're being like really
taking it very seriously.
Like,
you know,
you're what's wrong.
Uh,
not,
you know,
that's not funny.
Who made you do this?
Like just shit like that.
So it was just funny.
And then I saw some guy,
cause people are a clowning that they also started like a go fund.
Me,
the Mother did.
Oh what happened?
Cause I follow this Instagram account,
Hollywood um,
unlocked or something.
Yeah.
And that UFC guy was on there saying that he invited that boy,
but the mother was like,
don't invite him.
I'm not letting him go,
but you can promote my go fund me page.
And then he goes for what?
And she's like,
well Christmas is coming and I'm a single and I want money for my kids a fame.
So she's really,
really ruining this for her son by the way.
She's not cool.
People started,
go fund me for being bullied.
But there they're making a mockery of it.
Like uh,
this,
this guy here
looking out of like window blinds.
Like what's it say Tom Reese,
Nigga stay bullying me and shit and it,
and it's $100,000 goal.
How much does he had so far?
But it really made me laugh.
So,
yeah.
Yeah,
man,
I love people's,
um,
Internet,
things,
you know what I mean?
Like it's really healing the world when you take a stand against shit,
like,
oh,
come on dude.
I think it's funny.
I'm opposed to the terrorist attacks.
Well,
of course everyone is.
I think it's funny that people take this seriously.
That mean that take my tweets.
Right,
right,
right.
Are you talking about like,
yeah.
Well,
yeah,
that's,
you know,
that's what's gonna that's what divides us.
Yeah.
That's what,
that's,
that's the,
you know,
I tell you the Internet is pretty miraculous in that it exposes the,
the humanity of everyone and the joy.
Yeah.
And then the absolute dump fuckery of,
uh,
I'd say 80%.
I'd say we're at 80% retarded for,
for Boral.
What do you think?
I think when people,
I think the greatest,
I've said this before,
the greatest indicator of stupidity is when you don't process when something is
clearly a joke.
Yeah.
So there are so many people that don't process,
don't understand,
don't register sarcasm or satire.
Right.
Irony.
None of it.
None of it goes through their head.
That's the greatest indicator of a stupid person
that,
and I would say the folks who belong that God is sending hurricanes or fires
because of what gays are doing.
Like my mom stuff like,
well does she really think that it's to punish the gays and stuff like no,
no fuckers.
Fuckers.
It's that we need to be better people to each other.
Oh right.
Yeah.
That,
yeah.
We're not being good to each other were yeah.
And I'm like,
yeah,
yeah.
And then she's like,
and you know these hurricanes and I'm like,
ah,
God teaching us a lesson.
Huh?
Yup.
Well how come he doesn't reward us when stuff's going well?
Well he does life look all this amazing stuff.
Water's everywhere.
Yeah.
There's stuff like that.
I talked about it on stage about her POV of that.
I didn't do it this weekend,
but I had been doing it and about how at a certain,
like you have this conversation with her and I at 22 or three,
I am going to make sure every point that I have about that is expressed.
Oh boy.
And I know going to build into
a fight.
You tell me now that you think God sends the fires and I think about the energy
it would take to have that argument and then I just go like I know.
Yeah,
I know we got to do better to each other.
Isn't that the essence of middle age or approaching middle age?
I guess so.
You just,
you do this too tired.
The exhaustion mentally and spiritually that would take,
that's where the,
they're not giving a fuck is awesome at this age of your life.
There's so many things I don't fucking care about any.
I know things that used to really wind me up,
you know?
I don't,
I just don't have the energy either.
I could.
By the way,
it's so funny that this was a clip I could charge you with assault of what you
just did.
It's literally,
you had no idea this was what was planned.
It's literally part of the show today.
His former roommate or or teas in the amount of $596 he says after pulling a
prank on the defendant,
she viciously attacked him.
That's so his tooth.
You didn't lose your too,
but you chipped it.
Tipped it.
Yeah.
Oh,
just take a look at that.
On the plasma.
And she did look at that.
Ooh,
from the farm.
Well,
the risk taliation roommate and my sister knew him well.
How did the two end up getting shipped?
Basically,
it's going to sound a little gross,
but Vince is lactose intolerant and I don't know why.
Given his age,
he's not in third grade anymore,
but I liked ice cream.
He,
he's,
he probably doesn't like ice cream.
Yes,
your honor.
So I can cut.
We're getting into that.
He purposely ate some ice cream.
Right.
And he's lactose intolerant.
He knows what's going to happen.
The homeless man knows what ice cream does to him because he's lactose
intolerant and he tends to,
I know what light ice cream you'd,
however,
I don't like having ice cream thrown at my face and that's actually what she is.
What happened at all frozen hard brick of ice cream out of nowhere.
Just through.
So you can already tell he's a liar actually.
I think he's full of Shit.
Yeah,
I was taking a nap.
He had come home.
I sit.
I just need to make sure I'm hearing this correctly.
Did you fart in her face
moments before this podcast started?
You had sat here,
you recorded some ads and then I said,
hey,
I need to sit here to get back into this show.
You stood up and right here you farted.
I disgusting.
And I farted on your shoulder though.
Not In your face.
Let the judge explained some things.
Well,
I guess in a way,
yeah,
when I was walking the smell.
Did you smell my,
of course it's horrible.
What it smell like.
Anything in your presence regarding this party?
Oh boy has there.
So this is the sister now weighing in the end that that he's a habitual farter
that seems to be a regular part of his act.
He did make a lot of fart jokes during his act and he does tend to Fart a lot on
on purpose and all.
There's the occasional slip up,
but he does think it's funny to Fart on people.
It is funny.
That's funny about that.
I'm not arguing that.
I mean,
if we're in the court of what's funny,
I'd say this guy wins.
Yeah.
Because any evidence and the testimony before this court,
the gavel is going to come down in favor of the defendant because out of
everyone that was talking not real crazy about you,
you're a little mouthy,
but your sister,
she was sobbing.
Then one left thing here,
really ranking those performances.
Judge,
the judge says,
I think maybe you should pay attention to
when did you realize it or not,
but I talked about the chain of events.
When you farted on her,
I was in the salt.
A salt.
You don't have to put your hands on someone to assault them.
A fart is an assault far doesn't assault well,
it's interesting.
We learn something new every day on this show every,
every week rather.
So did I assault you?
That's what you're claiming of course.
And assault.
Yeah,
you did.
Yeah.
You did bart and her face.
Yes she did.
What are the damages?
I don't know.
$1 million,
$1 million dusting.
I'm for me for my emotional distress and that shit.
What did I,
what did I stop you from doing in your life?
From getting my mind together.
Confusing about the smell.
I think confusing about what did it smell like?
Let's talk about my farm.
It smelled really disgusting.
It really did well.
Like what?
Like Sour Shit.
Yeah.
Why do you smell so bad?
Because I went to the salad bar and I,
I get my a thousand ranch dressing.
I make it a Gelson's.
I thought of another one by the way,
where we were talking earlier about things that we think we are like,
you know when you,
when you like,
like it came up because it's had two is you're like,
I want to get a tattoo.
Like that lady.
Like you'll see somebody with like half sleeve or some color and you're like,
well then you go,
but that's not me.
You know what I always wanted want to be sounds like the leather bound,
a daily planner person.
Person once in my life I bought them because I love,
I love,
I love luggage and I love,
you know,
let like leather bound anything,
whether it's a backpack or a briefcase.
Like I just,
I have like,
I kind of fetishize,
romanticize any artists and work handmade,
handcrafted,
you know what I mean?
Anything like that.
I go like,
Oh,
I want that thing.
Then I get it and I,
and I don't use it.
I give you stuff that's leather bound a lot like bidding to it.
And then this is,
this is a little wallet I use of course,
but I'll hand you like a new thing and I'll go,
oh thanks.
Put it down.
It's gone forever.
And
anyway,
this,
yes,
this topic came up in regards to the Tattoo.
I mentioned I wanted my midlife crisis tattoo.
Yes.
And I thought about it.
I got many offerings.
No,
on my inner arm for Vitamin D,
it's never 2% it's all full milk,
whole milk,
whole verbal.
And I came to the conclusion that I may want it,
but I'm not the person who does it.
Like meaning I think I'm that girl.
But the truth of it is I shop at the gap and I'm super boring and like I don't
have the cahones boring.
I would say that you don't identify,
I'm too traditional.
Like part of me worries about being 80 years old and being in an airport because
I saw this woman at the airport who was like 70 old tattoo.
She didn't have a hassle,
but she had something on her leg that was so hideously inappropriate for her age
and I was like,
I can't do it.
It's just not me.
And there's a whole slew of things I wish I could be.
I wish I could be the girl when they take photos that they don't smile,
they just look like they're mouth is.
Yeah.
Cool.
But I always am like,
picture it like I'm so,
I'm like a Labrador.
I wanted to be the get up and grind exercise guy.
Like I exercise.
I work out a lot.
No,
I'm saying like I work out a lot,
but I've always read about and hear about the guy that gets up at like five dot.
Like Mark Walberg.
I follow them on Instagram.
He's up at four.
What are you doing with your life early?
Why?
I've tried it.
I hate it.
It's terrible.
I have to work out in the,
I can work out in the morning after a certain hour,
like at least eight.
I'd rather work at 11 cause I need to feel alive just to do it.
Well I'd be those people that wake up at like 4:00 AM fuck that their days start
earlier but they don't,
they work,
they start work at like seven fantasize about like being that that motivated
the guy that fucking grinds it.
Like from the sun before the sun comes up.
Oh God,
that sounds terrible.
I um,
the girl,
I also want to be as the one that wears high heels and has like beach wavy hair.
Like she cares.
She wakes up early and she curls it and then also is really into facial
treatments.
Her,
where is she?
She's here.
She's not in this house.
Oh right.
And the girl who's like really up on the facials and injections and like really
into like that level of self care.
You could be that girl.
Yeah.
But know how much energy that girl expense and when this shit,
I ain't got that kind of time.
No,
I'm an,
I also fantasize about being a motorcycle guy,
not like a fucking,
like in a bike game.
The motorcycle.
Like I'll see a beautiful bike and I'll go like,
ah,
and I've,
I've never written one and I don't really honestly don't want ride one.
When I like when I see them here on the four oh five and like weaving between
cars.
Oh that gives me anxiety.
Yeah.
What I do fantasize about is the open road in like Wyoming,
you know,
or you just see it like you just picture open road.
Maybe it's uh,
maybe it's on a ranch or something and there's like some dirt trails and I
fantasize like that be cool.
I'd like to do that.
But then I go,
I'm not gonna do that,
you know,
but I still lose myself in the thoughts.
Yeah.
Cause you'll see like a picture of someone and you're like,
I could be that person.
I have
stop myself from buying,
um,
luggage all the time,
just because like,
especially when it gets more niche,
you know,
I was like,
I bought a suitcase for our trip and they're like,
we have these backpacks,
we have these shoulder packs,
we have this.
So every time it's any type of compartment that you can get.
I'm like,
ah,
yeah,
yeah.
And I could put pens in that.
Yeah.
Like,
like I,
I just want,
I dunno,
I fantasize that light.
Okay.
Being that organized,
like that organized or just,
I like compartmentalizing things in a,
in a cool case.
Oh,
you know,
I like a cool box.
Yeah.
It's almost like a gadget noise.
You know?
It's not a gadget,
but it's like a cousin.
Right,
right.
That like the presentation of the thing,
it's like,
why a cool cigar box is cool.
It's like it's not the cigar,
the container,
the container it comes in.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
But then at the same time,
I'm aware of myself enough to not overdo it.
So I'll see that thing and I'll go like,
yeah,
and then I go,
you're not going to fucking use.
Well,
the thing too,
I've realized about my personality is that I can only own like five things at a
time because I'll buy,
I'll buy other stuff and then I'll forget it.
I'll be like,
oh,
I have that.
So are like,
I just don't,
I'll forget about it.
I honestly can only own five things.
I,
I'm with you on that.
I feel like I'll buy something nice like a nice shirt and then I'll see it in
the closet and I'll go like,
oh,
uh,
right now I'm going to run out and um,
go to the grocery store and then,
you know,
run it.
I Dunno.
Run another errand.
And I go,
she put on that shirt,
but I go,
but that's too nice of a shirt for that,
Aaron.
I do that all the time.
Yeah.
I'm saving the clothing for a special occasion and then we go like do that all
the time.
We're going to dinner tonight when I go into a nice guy,
I do that all one time.
I get a joint,
just save it for then we have vacation.
I go and I go.
But like,
yeah,
oh fuck it up on the vacation.
Yeah.
So I better leave it here.
That's a problem.
Why did the same thing?
I have a coat that you bought me fancy coat and I haven't found,
I found one occasion to wear it on so far.
Better fucking find it.
I don't know.
It's such a bummer and it's the most beautiful coat and it is a beautiful coat.
It's like really regretted getting it for you.
Thank you.
And I inherited these ridiculous fur coats from my mother when she died.
And those just stay in my closet like there is absolutely nowhere to wear a fur
coat and Los Angeles.
Sorry.
Are you crazy?
Only a crazy person buys real coats like makes and shit.
This isn't a bizarre isn't,
this is not an official dental outdate but as my as well,
it should be.
Embrace your fucking teeth brushed him.
Guide the empty.
I don't understand how you can walk around and not brush up like that.
Did your brand's bag ain't got teeth the dirty.
No ma'am.
They didn't have we role.
You know what I mean?
That is a,
yeah.
Yeah.
Jasmine masters.
She was on ru Paul's drag race.
Just making sure.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I like to clarify confusion in my brain.
That's a good idea.
But I liked the message.
I'm trying to on board 100% with her.
I need you to fix that.
Use a little car rocks you have to those Listerine,
the brown kinds.
I can get all straight through.
She's saying she's sick.
She's sick of foul mouth man.
You know,
who is she hanging out with?
I think she to hanging out with anyone's CD.
You to see that you see people with funky at miles all the time.
And the problem is what if you're close to one of those and how do you tell
them?
How do you tell somebody my world?
You just speak right up,
you know,
and comedian worlds,
you can,
you can be like,
Bro,
Shit's all fucked up.
Shit's all whack.
I've told people who have you told parents?
Oh,
well that's different.
You tell your mom and dad you were embarrassed about their mouth's daily.
I'm always like,
are you guys going to address that?
What?
They just laugh.
I know.
I don't know if they actually do anything,
but they do because they've told me.
My Dad called me.
He was like,
oh,
I just left the dentist.
He told me,
he called me that like a month ago.
Oh he did?
Yeah.
And how'd it go?
I Dunno.
I'm like,
did they rip all your teeth out?
I was like,
no,
get him clean bill of health.
I'm like,
you're going to a liar.
No,
but it was a little anything but get in between them.
Chief,
the front end,
the bag,
the size in them teeth.
She's got an safe.
Yeah,
I was just noticing and flossing does she,
she doesn't even mention philosophy.
That's the key to good dental hygiene is probably got hit on by someone with
fuck you.
Fuck you teeth.
That's a probably what?
You know what I mean?
It's like a event about inventing about that happening
and brushy Chris Mallon at Pima with in your teeth.
That's like cute.
Please get it together.
Just thank you.
Yeah.
I think that's what happened.
Somebody was like,
Hey,
what's
Cha?
Shit's nasty,
nasty,
nasty.
That's terrible.
I'm always so self conscious about that.
Yeah.
Bad,
bad coffee breath and stuff.
Yeah.
It's the first thing I do in the morning is,
I mean,
I don't know how anybody skips that step in the morning.
I told,
I talked about this years ago on your mom's house,
but uh,
I knew somebody whose mother would only brush her teeth once a day and she would
wake up,
drink the coffee,
and then go all day without brushing her teeth.
It was real crazy.
So then she would brush like by five o'clock and they're like,
you need to brush way,
way earlier.
How does it not bother you?
That's the thing.
She's like,
I don't like,
she goes,
I don't like the flavor of the toothpaste.
I don't like the taste of toothpaste.
And they said,
well,
you know,
you can get like cinnamon can get chocolate flavored,
whatever.
And so they did,
they got her the flavor she liked and then,
then she started doing it.
But you know,
that's somebody's mom,
bro.
It's really crazy.
That's a lifetime.
Uh,
Josh Weinstein was here last week.
Um,
and here we go.
Uh,
he promoted,
I need you to kill the documentary that I'm in.
I know.
I haven't seen it yet.
I'm so check it out.
A lot of people have been messaging me that they wash it,
so thank you.
You can rent it for a few bucks or you can buy it.
It's available on like all the pay per view cable things.
It's on iTunes.
It's on Amazon.
Um,
on indb some of our listeners,
I got into the trivia portion of the film.
Oh dear.
I'm,
so there's,
they're adding things all the time.
Tom was a denim enthusiasm.
Who prefers to what,
where high,
very tight fitting jeans.
Tom Lives a polyamorous bisexual life is life partner Christina.
They have a son named Jean.
Tom Considers himself a mommy just like we're seeing it as they say there.
There's two mommies and one gene.
Shortly,
shortly after this film was shot Thompson Grub again [inaudible] as a DJ named
dad mouth.
He gives his fans free tickets to Dj gigs.
Collaborates with a luminaries like Obi wan,
Kenoly,
Dj duct tape.
All these hymns or young patriotic gaping dad holds a yearly comedy benefit to
support the family of his dear friend Bert Chrysler lost his battle with
alcoholism and Jesus Christ.
Speaking of kill Tom's favorite movies and re portrait of a serial killer,
you just said that you watched something about Ted Bundy that you thought was
riveting and hilarious.
Amr,
I saw the Dahmer thing.
Somebody tweeted you the Ted Bundy thing.
I saw that on Twitter.
Somebody said,
is this a young teenage Tom?
And it was Ted Bundy being led down some courthouse stairs.
There's like a kid in the background smiling,
I think it was Vegas seven Oh two around a long time.
Vegas.
This says also the Tom's Griffin Asia to be amazed.
He was inspired to go on his trip by his spiritual advisor,
Kim,
and so that's really awesome.
That's really,
really nice to you to with that.
You think that the Wikipedia is and the imdbs of the world will figure out that
this communal posting thing is not really bringing forth truth in the world on
the Internet.
I don't know.
Just my Wikipedia page says,
I was born in Toronto and that is inaccurate.
Said fucking Dayton forever doing this.
Whose Windsor?
Ontario guys.
Glamorous.
Windsor.
Windsor Cross for five.
One three men.
They Twan.
Yeah.
Come on now.
I'm not that classy to be from the T.
Dot.
Yeah.
No,
I dunno.
People can just add what they want.
Then it becomes a fact.
I know.
And then I do all this press stuff,
but they're like,
you're born in Toronto and let it grow.
I get to ask the dating thing.
You're from Dayton.
I'm like,
dude,
I want to date you the first time I was probably 28 right there.
Like that's where you're from.
Like Kim deal.
Kim deal from Dayton,
Ohio.
Um,
what does this question here?
Somebody said,
is Joey Diaz insane?
Yeah.
I was listening on your recent podcasts was blown away when Joe,
he admitted to dropping a hot me brown in the shower and then physically picking
up with his bare hands and toss it in the toilet.
What's even more perplexing is that minutes after admitting shitting in the
shower three times in his life,
he said he was quoted to have said,
this is true.
You have to be an animal to shit on an airplane.
It made my dad Boehner flacid.
When I heard this,
I was confused and disturbed.
I had to change my pronoun.
Why does he think Browning and a plane bathroom is silver?
Pulsive but full on shitting in the shower and picking up your bare hands is
not.
I love the podcast.
I always look forward to Joey stories.
Please piss on me and beat me.
Try it out.
There's some Kansas.
Oh my God.
That's a new,
that's a new greeting.
Yeah.
Wow.
That was hilarious.
Piss on me.
Yeah,
try it out.
Try it out is the best part of that whole thing.
Try it out.
Come over here.
He's on black guys won't fucking fuck.
Oh good.
Oh my God.
That is fuck me.
Come over.
He wouldn't get out of prison.
Friends out and let's talk a pissed.
Let me try it out only as fuck,
man.
I'm looking for hardcore guys want to do it and I want to show I'm a hot salt,
my trash come down plus fuck.
He's also like trying to say so much and he's like tripping over his own words
from my fuck me.
I mean it's really,
really fine enough for it.
He's so excited to answer the email question about Joey.
It's because it's a lunatic person.
You're asking to think rationally.
Only somebody that crazy.
We'll go like,
yeah,
I pick up shifts in my shower,
throw them into the toilet,
but shitting on the plane,
of course he's not logical human being.
He's got his own code.
Yeah,
it makes sense to him,
which is what's amazing about him.
To be fair,
I think every human has their own sense of what's decent and what's not and
that's just Joey's logic.
Then again,
you know,
I think,
I think shitting on a plane is horrendous.
Then again,
picking up a low for shit and throwing it from the shower into the toilet's
pretty gnarly too.
I don't know.
Oh yeah,
that's true.
God,
I had such a messy brown the other day and I was so thankful for our birthdays.
So thankful there really are amazing.
I how did we even white before the downside of thinking about Hawaii.
I'm like,
well,
we'll be able to wash my ass ever time.
I really love it.
You know,
it's interesting.
Um,
I was talking to you the other day about when I was pregnant with Ellis,
how I could really smell things.
Like you have that pregnant lady smell and I remember when you would fart.
I could smell the layers to it.
Like some of it was nutty,
earthy,
so cool.
I could smell the oak tones,
I could smell the tonal qualities.
The fruit will cool.
Cool.
And then you go,
oh,
you're like a fart.
Somalia.
Yeah.
And I thought,
what a neat,
what any title and somebody out there is a fart.
Some all,
Yay.
Yeah,
you are.
What do you mean somebody out there you are,
you're a farm somewhere.
You only if I'm pregnant because that's,
that's like a pregnant lady superpower.
Is there smell?
Yeah.
But no,
you,
you are a far Somalia.
Yeah.
A R T I will say that when I go take,
when I go in the bathroom after you've taken a dump,
yeah.
You're after dump smells are sweet.
Oh I dunno what it is.
But your browns have either a very sour quality when they're sick,
you know when you've eaten shellfish or something.
But they're generally very sweet diabetes
far.
And Yeah.
Now he's supposed to be joined here any moment by the gray.
Pauly shore is a week.
I had to say it.
I grew up watching him.
Um,
I don't know where you're watching MTV back.
Fuck yeah,
that was like naughty.
He was so famous that and the movies,
I loved his movies as Christ.
You know,
my dad's favorite movie,
his son in law son in law was great,
which is no man Hilaire Encino man.
It was great.
Which is funny cause my dad obviously has that cultural divide of,
you know,
being like a hardcore Hungarian.
Yeah.
And it was so funny to always walk in on him just hysterically laughing at Pauly
shore and son in law.
He's like these guys so stupid.
He just loved it.
Yeah.
So for foreigners,
really our Intel,
you know,
let's take a quick break.
Okay.
Be here any moment.
Mommy,
let's take a break from there.
Okay.
All right.
So that was a,
that was exactly the right time to take a break.
I mean I turn this shit out.
Perfect.
And I have to say he was on time.
So,
um,
we're here with the great Pauly shore.
Thanks for coming over.
And this is exciting.
I haven't seen you since Tommy gave you a paid regular.
I know we keep missing each other various senior around once in a while,
but that's hilarious.
It's pretty surreal man.
Free,
surreal that you're here.
No,
I mean for both of us because we both,
like we both grew up in the MTV era cause you and I were talking once in the
green room at the store about,
you know,
a lot of the stuff you've done.
But even with the movies and everything,
if you go back to people that grew up with like MTV as like the cool thing to
the vjs thing is like for people that are,
I dunno,
under 30 listening or watching right now,
they don't,
they have no,
what MTV
was.
MTV was the only cool outlet there.
Well,
it was like there's,
there's like,
there's the network shows,
there's like a couple cable things.
There's only like fucking 30 cool.
Like whatever that was cool was and TV and I think Paula,
you tapped into it.
Like with the weasel it was like,
okay,
that's not how you say it by the way.
It's hilarious.
No,
it was like,
you know,
it's,
it's like a viral video.
It's like,
you know,
I did a Steven Miller video,
I don't know,
a couple months ago and it just,
it took off and then you do another video and it doesn't take off.
And it's like MTV,
everything lined up for me and every,
everything lined up for what was happening at the time.
I mean,
MTV was very east coast.
If you think back,
it was like,
you know Ken over in,
in and I don't know,
I mean fuck this downtown Julie Brown down to it was like east coast,
east coast and then I and Ed lover.
Yeah,
other Dr Dre.
Yeah.
And then I was sitting there,
I'm like fuck,
I got to get on there and then it just,
you know,
I don't want to break down the whole story,
but once I got on there it was something that was completely different and,
and the timing for me,
I was developing my stand up.
I was 17 when I first started doing standup and then,
and then my timing,
I think I was like 20 when I got on.
I mean you have to understand something.
Wow.
I was on MTV and my twenties in my twenties that's why your balls are drained.
There must've been so much mocks thrown on the streets.
That's awesome.
Oh wait a minute.
You start doing standards.
Yeah,
make twenties yeah.
Wait,
no,
my movies,
all my movies was in my twenties it's not like I did my movies and my thirties
my career like started to go down when I like had my run and uh,
in my thirties okay.
You know what I mean?
That's after all the movies and all the,
all the stuff.
Like that's when I stopped getting offers and all that shit.
Yeah.
[inaudible] offer stop because of like a bad cause movies.
The movie business is real crazy in that it's like,
just like in stand up,
it's like ticket sales driven I think.
I think I just didn't do with Dave Chappelle did,
which was he stopped while he was ahead for me.
You know what I mean?
In this should be a learning lessons to everyone out there when your stock is
high,
like back off,
you know d c I a little bit.
Yeah.
Like stop.
Like,
like for instance,
like I could have stopped after son-in-law.
Yeah.
Do you have any favorite movie by the way?
The most fantastic.
It's hilarious.
It's a fun thank you by the way.
Thank you.
Your Dad's got,
gets says yes.
It is hilarious.
Fun.
It's a great movie.
You made a lot of great movies.
Yeah,
I made it.
I made some really fun movies that I liked.
I like,
and I see my movies now and I love all of them,
but my point is,
is that I wasn't thinking all I want to do is work.
Right.
Do you know what I mean?
Like you like,
like they're like,
oh,
you're going to star in a movie and it's going to be about,
you're going to be on jury duty and there's going to be Stanley to cheese in it
and you've got all these great actors in it and,
and you know,
Tia career,
a Wayne's world involvement.
And I'm like,
fuck,
that sounds good.
Of course,
jury duty sounds Hilarious,
but you know,
I didn't work good with the director.
The producer,
the script was weird.
The,
you know,
everything was like didn't line up.
It wasn't like it lined up on my other films and because I was above my name was
above the title.
I fucking suffered from it.
Right.
You know what I mean?
By the way.
I've always wanted to ask this to somebody with your,
like,
with the experience of doing that,
when you're making a movie,
do you have the best thing in the world?
I imagine that literally the best thing in the world,
you ever have any sense when the movie's being shot?
Do you sense like this is not going to go well?
Like do you feel that on the ones that kind of,
yeah,
kind of.
But then you also,
it's like when I did I bring back the Steven Miller video just because it was my
last recent thing that did well.
Like I did that and I didn't know I was going to wind up on CNN being talking to
like one of the CNN newsroom.
Yeah.
That was really funny for people that don't know though.
Stephen Miller,
uh,
works in the Trump administration.
He's one of the presidential aids and he came out and like basically took them
Mike one day.
Now this is on the way of Spicer going out and really talked a lot of shit to a
lot of the reports.
Hilarious.
And,
uh,
and then,
Polly did like a parody of it where he had like the,
the fucking horse shoe,
the bald head.
And it's very funny man.
It was beautiful.
Thank you.
See that's a funny or die funny or die.
But my point is is that you do things in you,
you know,
you can't control all the other antics that happens so you can just do what you
do and then,
and then it's like it's in God's hands,
you know,
as far as a hit,
you just don't know.
You don't know when you have an outcome.
But in retrospect,
do you feel like you would have strategized in,
in terms of like,
absolutely.
I'll take my agents and managers told me not to do it.
Of course they are like,
you know,
even when I did in the army,
now they told me not to do that because I had got a,
I just signed a three picture deal at Disney and I didn't see no man.
First they did son in law and the next they,
Jeffrey Katzenberg who is running Disney at the time wanted me to do another
movie there.
And new line came to me with this other film called totally London,
which was basically me playing an AU pair in London,
you know like poly Poppins,
like where I go,
where I go over there,
you know,
if my slang or whatever it is,
and I live with this kind of English family and,
and we wanted to do that.
But because I was in bed with Disney and Jeffrey Katzenberg,
they wouldn't get me out of that deal.
So Jeffrey said,
shut up,
you're going to do this movie.
And that's what we did in the army now and in the army now did well like now
it's made its money after years of it being out there.
But at the time it didn't do as good as the other movies did.
So that was like,
and then I cut my hair and I was so known for my hair,
my hair.
Can we please talk about,
are we going to cut Dahlia's hair?
We got to take it up because he's getting too much paper
for me.
You want a mean?
Yeah.
That doesn't work for me.
He though I
feel like the weasel,
you could've found that guy anywhere on the sunset sunset strip and that era of,
of time,
because it was like the,
the metal clubs.
You remember.
I'm like,
the sunset strip was kinda that dude very well.
Could have been living there.
How did you,
how did he come to you,
first of all,
before you even answer that,
can we start so that people know that Pauly,
like where he grew up?
Oh my God.
You're the craziest life ever.
Like would they like,
so that they know the background,
your,
your mother,
Mitzi shore.
Um,
the,
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It just goes out when you mentioned my mom.
I know.
See me don't,
don't bring me in on this bull shit.
Leave me alone.
I don't want to have a fee.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
So areas like Holly's mom,
you know,
ran the comedy store and Paulie basically grew up at the comedy store with his
dad's a comment.
Yes,
of course.
And,
uh,
I met your dad and,
and uh,
there's,
you know,
he's got Sam Kennison babysitting him and crazy.
Rodney and I just as crazy as thriving.
He was the best.
Really?
Oh my God.
So hilarious.
Just always,
oh yeah,
he was the best.
I believe that.
Yeah.
He was the bass and sweetheart and funny and all that stuff.
To Christina's point,
do you at an early age,
because it's almost,
it seems normal to you.
Do you go like,
I'm going to do this,
I'm going to do what all these people are?
Well,
I have two brothers and a sister and they're not into it.
So it's like they grew up in it as well.
I mean,
you guys know you guys are straight comics.
You guys are hardcore comics.
Like you don't choose it.
It chooses you like,
like you live fucking in the valley.
Like you guys have to drive to the comedy store.
Do you think you like driving the comedy store?
No.
Yeah.
But you fucking know once you get up there,
you're gonna have that feeling and that you know that it's especially like you
guys got to drive to the fucking airport.
Yeah.
And flight,
you know all over America.
Do you like that?
No,
but you know what's going to happen when you get there,
right?
People are going to be there for you and your heart is going to be open.
You're going to feel this like stressful lever,
you know what I mean?
So is your first time on stage at the store?
No,
I stayed away from it for about two years.
But you were like did your mom,
because I knew why I started when I was like 17.
I started when I went to Beverly Hills high school and I was like in a,
I was in,
it was in high school is at the beginning of 12th grade and all my friends were
going to college.
They were taking the sat papers and I'm like,
okay,
now I've got to start.
So I just started.
Angel Salads are actually wrote my first joke.
He wrote my first joke.
So,
uh,
so he got me,
he got these,
I got these comics,
let's start kind of writing me jokes cause I didn't know how to write jokes.
And then my dad took me to my first gig.
He did dad with you?
Yeah,
my dad's pretty cool.
it is.
It's called the city.
Yeah.
Feel pressure because it was your father or did you feel supported because it
was your father?
Do you know what I mean?
It can be either way.
Um,
no,
he was cool.
He was cool.
My Dad was cool,
you know,
but I always like,
it was,
it was just one of those things that I always knew I was going to do and like,
okay,
now I'm going to do it.
But I stayed away from the store for two years and there was a club called the
alley cat B's.
Strowe and that was it.
No,
that was where,
that was my first time.
No,
the La Cabaret was a club in the valley.
Do you remember it?
It's not there anymore though.
Yeah.
I don't mean that was so long ago.
So a guy named ray bishop who used to own an argus Hamilton,
used to get me spots there.
And then I worked with Jamie at the laugh factory for years.
Yeah.
So I stayed away from the store and then the first time I went on from my mom,
I showcased for her.
And then what kind of pressure is that?
Terrifying or,
yeah,
it was a nightmare.
It was,
it was a nightmare because I also figured you're either going to be like,
no was no big deal or yeah,
it's a fucking night.
Know.
It was fucking terrible.
I was 19,
you know what I mean?
And she tell you,
well,
let me finish.
No,
uh,
no.
So,
so Paul Mooney in lieu in,
uh,
Paul Mooney and Louie Anderson were sitting next to her in the booth,
her booth.
So I go on stage,
it's packed.
Obviously there's like a wall full of comics.
I don't want to say they hate my guts,
but it's Mitzi son,
you know,
so they're like in the way back.
So I'm like,
I'm like on stage,
I'm doing these really bad jokes that angel told me that I wrote for me.
I grew up in Beverly hills,
my mom's Mexican,
whatever.
What am I just,
sorry.
I say my jokes,
no lapse.
So at the end I break out and start pop locking.
I had this boombox,
we played freakazoid and I put this mask on and I stuck because I was good at
pop locking.
Yeah.
So I started popping and then after I went off stage,
I ended good.
I have to,
I'm like,
how did I do it?
She's like,
stick with the dancing.
My mom sits gig with the dancing and then she's like,
get away from me.
It was like pretty bad.
Yeah.
So like it's not till I became famous on MTV and I was like drawing people in
the main room that she like made me a paid regular.
Yeah.
Like I literally had to stay away.
And then I worked with Tennyson for a long time.
Why did you wait?
Hold on.
When did you with Kennison?
What do you mean you worked with him?
You Open for him?
Yeah,
I opened for him.
Wow.
That was cool.
So is that the birth of the weasel?
The weasel back?
I'd have to say it was Kinda like all my friends used to call me the weasel.
They did?
Yeah.
Like when I was younger.
And then a lot of comics like Jackson,
Purdue,
he's the city,
you're a weasel.
And then I was always like waste.
So like I'm the one that Kinda came up with that.
And then I was like,
if someone could,
if that noise can actually occur,
what would that noise sound like?
And I was like,
you know,
that's where the thinking.
And then I started like pausing between my words that was on MTV,
that was like,
I would look in the camera and be like,
check out this video broke cause it's going to be made.
Sure.
And then I start crying,
grind it,
and then I would just start making shit up.
And then it was like my own language to the audience.
And then,
and then from there,
you know,
I was like kind of had my own slang to the audience.
The juice that was from Encino.
Man,
Julie's you use.
So that's how it took off thing about it is like as a kid too know,
like,
uh,
somebody who's a little bit older than you and is cool.
So cool.
And then when you learn slang because you're as a kid,
it's like,
what does that mean?
Yeah.
So like it was hearing the slang on MTV,
but then in the movies too,
that you're like,
aw man.
And then you do it on the playground.
You do it cool.
Like we're all doing crazy Pauly shore at school.
It was pretty cool.
Yeah,
it was cool.
that's wow.
It was like the best,
I mean,
it was like,
people are always like,
oh,
you always hear,
people are like,
oh,
why do you talk about your passing?
I'm not just me.
Just people in general.
You know what I mean?
We'll show you,
you live here pass.
And I'm like,
well,
you didn't live in my past.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
My Pass was insane.
Yeah,
of course.
You know,
it was,
it was pretty fucking.
Yeah.
Cool.
So can you been on a ride that most people never will?
Never will.
Can I ask you,
cause I had,
my mother's gone now,
but I had a mother who very much disapproved of me and never really gave me the
thumbs up the approval.
I so desired like,
do you think there's a time that your mother saw your career and,
and went like,
yeah.
You did it.
Yeah,
she gave it to him
pretty much and that looks good on them.
I wish I would have had a daughter.
Um,
yeah.
You know,
when I became famous on MTV and I was fine,
I took her to the MTV awards,
you know,
I was with dating a porno star newer,
so she liked that.
Yeah.
She was like,
who are you dating?
Is it a well known name was Savannah.
Oh,
I know Susanna.
She's popular on the stern show.
Yeah.
Don't they?
Don't they play it?
She's been dead for a long time.
She came over myself.
Oh my God.
I'm sorry.
No,
but probably may hope.
I hope not difference.
No.
Uh,
no,
this,
this was 1994,
so,
uh,
yeah.
So,
uh,
yeah,
my mom was cool.
Obviously,
like,
so liberal and so like whatever.
My mom never judged and that's out.
That's what I loved about my mom.
And that's like me.
Like I don't judge people,
like if you're a heroin addict,
whoa,
cool.
That's your thing.
Like,
you know what I mean?
yeah,
people have to go through what they have to go through in life.
And,
and my mom was such,
you know,
that my mom was such an artist.
Like she was so she,
her heart was the comics.
That's where her well at,
sir.
Come on.
And it actually started with my dad because my dad met her when he was cheering
in the 50s and my dad was touring in any,
any did a,
a camp.
He did a,
it was a summer camp in Elkhart Lake,
Wisconsin.
And my dad was the comic there.
And my mom used to,
my mom used to type up his jokes because she was,
because she was the assistant for the owner,
the owner of the camp,
and she'd be like,
do this one,
do that.
So it was like a natural thing.
Yeah.
So that was her thing.
Did.
Um,
then that's so,
well now I don't know if you've been asked this a million times,
so forgive me if you have,
but do you have any opinion on the showtime series?
I'm dying up here.
Um,
I,
you know,
I told people a million times exactly my take on it for people.
Just the people that,
that
don't know.
It's basically,
I mean,
it's executive produced by Jim Carrey and it's,
you know,
it's a play on the,
what did they call
your mom's character?
Not winning many or something.
You're right.
So it's like a woman running the club.
I mean,
it's obviously,
it's supposed to be symbolized Mitzi,
but,
sorry.
So just so people know.
So when I see,
I tell every time I see Erik Griffin,
I was like,
dude,
I'm suing you bro.
Like you're playing a,
playing it wrong.
I'm coming after you.
He's like,
it's not me.
I'm like,
dude,
I don't give a fuck attorneys,
they're going to,
you're going to be getting a cop.
No.
Uh,
no.
I guess it's,
you know,
I mean,
Jim Carey,
you know,
he,
it's his take on the whole thing,
right?
So it's not my take.
It's not my mom's take,
it's not my dad's steak.
It's his day.
That's true.
So that's the first thing.
The second thing,
I look at it,
I look at it at two,
two things.
I look at it.
Number one,
do I like this as a show?
You know,
and you just kind of sitting there and watching it and I think it's kind of cool
cause I like kind of historical shows.
I like shows from the 60 70 days.
I'm like that,
that era.
And then you look at it as a show show,
not really feeling it that much.
You know what I mean?
I'm not really connecting with people.
Does that make sense?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Like I like,
I think they're all good actors,
but let's be honest,
they're not all good act.
I mean not to,
not to disrespect any of them,
but they're not real actors there comedians that are acting.
Does that make sense?
Because I watched the whole series.
It's about standup and I know these people,
I think they made it too heavy.
It was too fucking dark.
It was like,
I'm going to kill myself if I don't get on the main stem.
Imagine if that was done with real good actors,
then that would be pretty kind of cool.
No,
I don't know.
I don't know if it's the acting or the fact that,
I mean,
imagine if like there,
Sean Penn's we're doing it.
Who are the,
who was like,
our generation is Sean Penn's and like in Robert Downey and those type of guys,
you know,
where they kind of really becoming,
they should have cast I think,
I don't know,
maybe Gosling.
I don't know though.
I don't know.
I think it's a fair to,
I mean I like,
I like your take.
That's a very honest take and I don't think there's anything wrong with it.
Um,
but I'm happy that it's got picked up for a second season and it's because it's
cool for the guys.
You know,
when they got,
they got,
they got a Gig,
you know what I mean?
At the end of the day,
you get to fucking show up and act for fucking three months on a show.
What's better than that?
It's great.
You know what I mean?
So do you,
um,
do you,
so how did the,
doesn't know what to ask me.
I think it's finished.
[inaudible] Bro.
Sorry.
You can cut that part out if you
slow it down.
So wait,
I want to do,
how do Steven Miller thing come about when,
I mean obviously that happened,
but how did you do?
They just asked me to do it.
They just,
they just thought of you.
I do,
I do funny or die stuff a lot,
so I'm always doing stuff for them.
So they just,
Sean Boyle,
who's a friend of mine over there,
it with Mike Fair,
they're just,
hey,
you know,
Stephen Miller just did this thing on CNN and we want you to play the blah blah
blah.
And I'm like,
okay.
And the next day I went in and did it and they put it up,
you know?
Yeah.
What about you guys?
How did you guys,
I mean this is an interesting thing.
Well,
no,
you're right.
It's not supposed to work.
I mean,
you mean you saw,
you've seen it with your parents like two people,
a cook.
Mom was in a comic.
You guys are full on really good comedians that are successful and you're
working.
This is a sitcom.
You got to develop it in a show
for sure.
Oh God.
It's great financing yourself though.
100% yeah,
do it Louis C K did except for the other party can reason with no cause you can
produce it.
Get a young producer and there and just pay for it half,
half and then just shoot whatever it is you want.
Edited,
sizzle,
get up man.
And I work because we started at the same time.
Oh that's cute.
Tommy.
Tom,
Tom Seger.
I mean literally since he was 23 I watched him.
I think I met you like the fifth time you went on stage.
We were rooting for each other like coming in at different levels
but the weasel is he going to get when your baby,
when your baby came out?
I did.
You have did three minutes.
Just Atlanta Boys,
my head.
Oh my God.
It's definitely a show there.
I mean for sure.
Like on the road who opens for
Natasha and
that we didn't do,
we didn't do that dynamic because trouble better to keep it separate.
That's the first episode.
And then you guys do and it's a disaster and you guys are just filing for
divorce.
That's a good angle,
right?
Larry Sanders
will never work together again.
I think that'd be great.
Yeah.
I got a 50th birthday coming up and you're going to do a book.
I should.
Oh my God.
I got so many things.
I got two documentaries.
I have,
um,
uh,
about three years ago I did stands along,
which was on showtime,
which is a straight doc and now I have a doc series based off of that and that's
a six part series and I've finished.
That's fucking,
I think,
not to pat myself,
but I think it's the best thing I've ever done.
It's very emotional.
I moved my mom out of the house.
It's fucking heavy,
dude.
Good.
Toby,
excuse me.
Just
going to put a ring on this finger or what are you going to with Whitney
Cummings?
You're going to marry her?
I to it really keeps the,
she keeps ignoring me.
I just wanted to get her pregnant.
Yeah,
do really into animals.
You just have to start letting the animal
do get her a horse and have a horse.
I want to say it.
I don't know.
I mean I'm,
I'm,
it's like bungee jumping from me.
Like I kind of liked being alone.
I mean,
I have a girlfriend now.
I've been seeing her for a while.
We have a nice relationship,
but it's really difficult for me.
You know what I mean?
It's difficult for me to just be with someone all the time to come home.
Like I like coming home and I'm by myself.
I kind of liked that.
Well,
we were just talking about how we go away for the holidays to avoid family.
I don't necessarily enjoy hanging out with all my family members and that's just
your wiring and I respect that you know that about yourself because there are
some men that aren't supposed to have families.
I don't think.
Honestly,
my dad was supposed to be a family guy.
He stuck around.
He did his duty,
but my dad enjoyed it.
It was miserable.
I was miserable.
My parents divorced when I was three years old,
but before that I,
you know,
I have
two brothers and a sister,
but my oldest brother is Scott.
He's like 64 and my sister's like 60 to 60 so it's like
a long time.
When do my debt,
Whoa,
sorry about that.
My Dad's fucking 90 years old.
My Mom's 87 so it's like they were doing it a long time ago and then they
stopped and then they had me and my brother Peter.
So me and Peter were pretty much raised at the store.
You know what I mean?
The whole time while mom was dating our guests and in dating,
like Danny stone and all these different comedians and I was just there running
around and artists still visits her,
right?
Like,
yeah,
he's like very dedicated.
That's,
yeah,
that's very sweet.
It's very sweet.
He would Garry Shandling visitor too,
and then he left and he passed away.
Not Good.
Why are you laughing?
That's not cool.
That's politically incorrect.
This,
what seen what movies is from one of my favorite scenes.
I forget what movie this is from.
Of you
breath.
God's love to fuck.
Fuck.
Look,
if you're a hot black guy and you want to fuck me a 2195 if you want to move in,
you can move in.
But you got to fuck the,
I try my movie.
It's not,
oh no,
no,
no.
That's the wrong clip.
Publicist sent us the wrong trailer.
I am my publicist.
Oh Shit.
We got the fucking bamboozled.
Holly,
what do you think is going on in that clip?
I don't know.
I don't know who.
I don't even know if that looked like sandy.
Dan.
No.
Oh,
we don't know.
It's a guy on the Internet who just gave out his address and one a black guys to
come over and fuck him.
And if you're out of jail,
do piss on him.
Come on him.
Whatever.
Try now since it's a family show,
it's his mother's house.
Your mom's.
That's true.
It's not,
yeah.
You music,
right?
Uh,
are you a fan of the show?
Gigolos on showtime.
We not seen it in a while and seen it.
Well,
it's about,
there's a bunch of mail hose on showtime and it follows them around,
you know,
turn in their tricks and their lives and stuff.
I haven't seen it.
Oh.
One of the guys on there is a musician.
He has a new music video out.
Um,
and they asked us to take a look at it.
So let's give us your honest take.
Yeah.
I love this song.
You do?
Yeah.
I like the song.
I don't know their version of,
it's a little,
oh wait,
wait.
You know this,
I know this song,
right?
It's someone else's song.
I Dunno.
Is it?
Yeah,
that was wrecking ball.
Yeah.
Oh,
well,
he did a remake of it.
I didn't know that.
Got good ear.
Yes.
Are they going to start fucking or what?
No.
Come on already and want them to bang or Vegas baby.
That's it.
That's all that's happening.
Sure.
That's cool.
Cool.
All right.
Anyways,
it's,
no,
no.
Lisa,
no one I adore.
Yeah,
that was funny,
man.
That was good.
I'm a stony,
crusty dude.
Yeah,
no,
it was Lisa Real,
was it based on a real Lisa?
Yeah.
Where is she now?
She lives in Nashville with her kids.
You're going to try and make a baby though,
right?
I think so.
Really?
Yeah.
I think that that makes sense to me.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But I keep pulling out.
You gotta stop.
You gotta leave out of this full loads all the way inside.
Yeah.
Missing the vagina.
Right.
You can't do a half a load and then it gives me and then Joo out go,
wait,
no I didn't.
And you also got to,
you got to make sure she lays still there after a while.
It's hard to not move your legs up,
legs up.
I heard if you do it doggy style,
then it's a boy.
And if it's standard then it's a girl hold it until her children.
That's true.
Yup.
So what do you guys have?
We have a boy.
Yeah.
So you did her dog dog food to
Valet Park.
Yeah,
we did 69 we were talking about people do people really 60 to 69 like a thing
you do.
Once in high school and then the long time not good.
He's like,
I know I don't do that now.
Right.
It's kind of weird
like,
wait,
you guys are live in the valley.
You guys live in a valley house.
So do you guys have sex in the valley and stuff?
This is cool.
Like you guys got neighbors and stuff,
you know,
suburban,
suburban.
Let's cause we have a kid.
I mean,
where the fuck do you raise your kid?
I grew up in La.
I grew up out here.
You grew up in the valley?
Birmingham?
No,
I went to Louisville.
All Girls Catholic.
But I had friends.
I went to Birmingham.
So you're in the valley.
That's cool.
But where are you from originally?
Originally I was born in Cincinnati,
but I moved,
I moved a lot.
So I lived in a lot of Midwest.
Yeah.
When did you start,
where did you start doing your stand out here in la?
Which club?
Uh,
well I started at like some of the bars and then I got in at Melrose first.
The improv,
if you could say the problem in front of me,
it's okay.
I don't want to upset you.
What's crazy is when I first started working the Improv's,
I actually put in my contract,
it was tea.
I put a curtain in front of me because I didn't want someone to take a picture
in front of the Improv sign.
Show it to my mom.
Yeah,
sure.
You know,
cause that was like a very big,
you know,
feud growing up as a kid,
you know?
Of course.
Very important question.
Do you ever,
when you take a dump,
do you ever go right to the shower from shit to shower?
I'm not going to talk about that.
Why a good conversation
all the time.
You think he wants to put that on there,
put that it's a bad energy.
She's talking about,
she's talking about not even wiping.
No,
because no,
she's done those jokes before on stage.
I done some shit jokes before.
This is your mom's house.
We have to be real to the brand.
You know who
you know who I sat next to yesterday on my flight set directly next to me was
Kenya and Martin.
Who's that?
I'll tell you exactly who that is.
Arm didn't go the way,
you know what I'm saying?
He made clear at the end it was a question and we'll try,
we'll call,
you know what I'm saying?
I didn't go our way.
I had a good look at see how to better look.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean for me,
I always just think of him as university of Cincinnati,
but he played in the NBA for,
I don't know,
it doesn't here.
He was a,
I forget a bit of a journeyman.
Right.
He had a few teams.
Um,
let me look up his,
so he's,
he's retired now,
but I'm saying he's a,
let's see what his,
his career was at big old fuck six,
nine.
He played for the nets.
The nuggets.
The clippers.
Yeah.
Bucks.
Oh,
a whole bunch of teams.
Jersey.
Yeah.
Do you like sports?
But he's one of the all of the all time.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh,
it was just books and they made,
they made one more close and we did it the one night the game got out of
control.
And so they came out with a lot of Angela,
which we knew there was going to do.
I mean,
there's a lot of them,
you know what I'm saying?
I know what I'm saying.
You know what I'm saying?
I know what I'm saying is
what I'm sending for.
You know what I'm saying?
He says we always like to highlight things.
They're really great.
You know what I'm saying?
So yeah,
I think that's the open for your show.
You know what I'm saying?
Guys talk about you're in the kitchen and you're doing the kid thing and it just
turns into like,
look,
we're getting paid a lot of money.
You know,
and you're like,
yeah,
but that's the one thing we talked about.
We would never work together.
You know what I mean?
And then finally you just say fuck it,
let's do it,
let's just do it.
And then it's all this angst and he'd go up there and something bad happens,
you know what I mean?
And then like that's the end of the second act.
And then the third act is like,
you know,
you kind of deal with it.
And then like,
you know,
you start,
yeah,
I liked this premise because that is the one thing we've chosen.
Because you know,
once you do a reality show,
it kills the marriage.
No,
you're not reality.
Just a straight script.
But I'm saying there's a reason we've never done certain things.
I,
I feel like,
yeah,
maybe unconsciously we knew that the thing that's cool.
Yeah,
it is.
You guys are both really talented and you guys can like do something different
because no one's done it.
No one's done it successfully.
Right.
The,
the,
the husband and the wife that are both true standups,
right?
I mean,
right.
Is there any,
well,
I mean,
okay.
Lucien Reiki.
They weren't standing there.
They came out of Vaudeville.
Who's the,
uh,
you're right.
There's not been too married,
true standups that have done no thank you.
It would be great.
And you just tweak it.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's a good idea.
Are you guys already know this idea,
but you should just get it done.
I think it'd be great.
Yeah.
Working on it,
man.
We really are working.
We really are.
It's really,
so the reason she asked you about 69 so,
um,
you want to talk about shitting and black guy's penis.
What about six to nine
Nigga,
all the way over the black guy's penis possibly.
Have you ever seen that website?
Black [inaudible] dot com no.
You're talking about black penises and you haven't seen black and.com it's a
website dedicated to black guys having sex with white girls.
You mean black?
Oh,
black and Tom,
I'm going to correct.
Okay,
so it's black.com.
Yeah.
Wait,
is that part of the dog fart network?
Maybe.
What is happening?
Maybe because this dark web is this stuff I'm,
but I've just heard stories,
basically a website that's just get it dedicated to black guys having sex with
white girls,
but they're hot white chicks and they,
and they have sex with the girls in the butt.
Yeah.
Oh,
you guys all have tiny little dicks.
It's the funniest thing.
It's really,
it's like a new take on it.
They're like,
you think black guys normally a big decks and not over here.
And then that's where they can fit so many in the Pauline,
how many women?
I don't want to ask the number,
but I'm,
I want to ask like I feel like how many,
what was it like in the,
it must've been the MTV.
What was crazier MTV era or like,
like movies after that.
What was a combination?
But there is one lane of it crazier than the other or no,
they both.
I was on the TV during the whole time I was doing the movies.
Oh,
okay.
It was like mixed.
Yeah.
I was doing an album's
HBO movies,
the whole thing.
Craziest.
Like when you go to Daytona to do an MTV thing,
is that right about spring break?
Spring break.
That's got,
must have been off the chain.
It was the best.
You're like,
I can't come anymore.
There's no more in me.
I can't,
no.
I had this friend of mine,
Tony to Sant.
I'm going to see in New York.
You guys know Tony.
You know Tony,
right?
Right.
No,
he's not.
No.
He's a producer.
He's,
he ran,
he ran from jail.
Homeless
if ran MTV for a while.
So you know Tony.
Okay.
So Tony was,
um,
he was like a,
sorry,
go ahead.
He was Tony's a,
he was a producer at spring break when we were doing the chicken with the we
shows.
Right.
And,
um,
they used to come to my room,
the producers would come in my room to prep me,
you know what I mean?
To kind of like,
you know,
they just hate this.
They're going to do,
he was on the show,
blah,
blah.
And he came in my room and you know,
girls were in there already from the night before and then he come out and then
I'm like,
wait dude,
I got it.
I got,
and this is,
he says this,
so don't think I'm a pig for saying this.
I didn't say this.
He says that,
uh,
Polly blah blah blah.
There's a splint on my dick or something.
Like I had a splint on my dick.
That's what he said.
I don't remember saying that.
Ask Him,
but you know,
did you have a game set up where you'd be like,
Hey,
like go,
I didn't have to have what
I'm saying.
Like I'm saying,
if you eyeballed someone,
you're working,
this is like,
hey babe,
that's it's up.
That's it.
Hey Babe,
what's up?
He just
literally rubbed my arm,
went,
hey,
that's how the electricity,
that's it.
Get into a room.
No,
it was um,
it was cool.
You know,
it was a spring break.
You had a,
who is that?
Lenny Kravitz was there.
Uh,
Rodney was down there at Kennison was down there.
Cheap trick was down there.
Black Crow stone,
temple pilots.
Um,
you find out,
cannibals,
you know,
and it was just like,
you know it with live.
Yeah.
That's what was cool.
And it was an event.
Spring break was the biggest event for MTV.
So you had hundreds of thousands of kids going in and going there just to be on
spring break,
you know,
it was like,
and it was live.
So it's like,
you know,
if you fucked up,
you fucked up,
you know,
your whole,
Veejay Shit.
You know,
he just,
that's how it,
what did you love the Gig?
It was a great case.
Yeah,
because it was like,
you felt like a Rockstar,
you know?
Yeah.
So it was a,
I was so lucky.
It was very fortunate,
you know.
That's very cool.
Um,
okay,
so the reason that she's bringing up 69,
it's an important reason.
So when my dad turned 70 this summer,
my mother,
who's a foreigner,
she's from Peru.
She
uh,
we asked you have white stuff over your notes.
Hey,
yeah,
we asked her,
we said Dad's turning 70 tomorrow will you?
69 [inaudible] 70.
And it became like a joke at the dinner table because she also didn't know what
that meant.
Right.
So it was like a funny thing and people started doing it.
So anyways,
we told our audience about that and they have been recording their families
asking the same question and sending in the claim.
We have some,
here we go.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
How old did you turn today?
69 69.
Um,
so before you turn 70,
like on the last night,
are you going to try to 69 one more time?
I don't think smarter with what my dog,
you're going to keep them jeans high and tight,
so,
right.
That's Alec and Bailey.
That's fantastic.
She had a good attitude.
Yeah,
because some moms are,
they very man.
Shut it down.
Yes.
Grandma,
grandma,
grandma.
There you going to 69 moving to celebrate
John.
It's a 16 on Earth.
See,
somebody yelled at him,
John.
That's what that was like.
Stop.
Stop doing that.
They were reprimanded for the fun.
Fun to celebrate his last night being 69.
Do you think you guys will 69
you're not gay.
Be Gay.
That where you think?
I don't think so.
That is fantastic Katie.
Um,
that's a good one.
Thank you Katie for saying that we don't usually have the women,
uh,
record they'd been,
the guys have been sending it in,
but Katie sent it in,
so thank you for that.
Her Dad don't eat nothing with hair on it.
That was a good response actually.
It's a good mom.
They're in Alabama.
Uh Oh.
Do you think for that 70th birthday to celebrate,
you guys are going to 69.
What do you think that man,
the fuck is wrong with you?
I love you.
Yes.
Those are my favorite responses.
Yeah.
When they're just like,
why are you being a child?
Like why are you doing this?
Juvenile?
It should have pushed him a note.
I know.
Hilarious.
No,
three real,
you guys should,
it's the last time anything.
Yeah.
Sanji
on Dad's 16 ninth birthday.
The last day.
I'm going to give the guy in the 16th year right before I turned 70 exactly.
What are you guys going to go out with a bang and 69 one last time.
Do you do it
every night?
So embarrassed,
but I've done it.
Do it,
She said,
look how excited.
Dad.
What about the guy?
Little Tiaras guy in the corner.
He's like joining Isis.
I know.
It looks like my friend Romy.
Romy,
what's up?
So that's a,
that was Benji.
We got a couple more here.
This is a question to ask you,
Christa.
Oh,
you and dad are getting older.
This is fantastic.
And not this
dad's about to,
he's not about to turn 70 but he's in his seventies so he's not in his 70
[inaudible] he's about to be in the seventies so the night before his 70th
birthday,
when he's 69 are you in a 6,969 what?
You asked your mother that counseling but buddies,
are you going to um,
I don't know.
I don't think it would just discuss this with you.
Fucking leaf blower.
I think she's going to do it.
Oh Geez.
So horny.
Horny.
Right.
What about me?
I'm 49.
I'm going to be,
what am I going to do?
My,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
What is that?
50 of is a big one.
Yeah,
but what do you do 50th?
I think you have to,
you have to do a sexual stuff.
We do have to do sexual stuff.
What are you doing?
Have you been pegged?
What does that mean?
Like a girl straps on a little low inputs in my,
but yeah,
but also like reaches around and cranks went out for you.
That's a big 50th thing.
Really?
Yeah.
Would you not let a girl do that?
Maybe if I was wasted.
There you go.
Yeah,
but you're going to be a fight.
If I put like some,
uh,
muscle relaxers in my body,
you know what I mean?
Listening to rectum,
you don't have to relax for something like that to go down.
I don't do bud sucks,
but there's a reason.
Yeah.
No,
I mean,
yeah,
it's a tight,
not tight.
I love how she got really,
she got,
she said I'm gonna send you in a counseling.
Yeah,
right.
Did you say that?
She goes
because to in the seventies,
so the night before his 70th birthday,
when he's 69 or [inaudible] 69.
Why don't you ask your mother that,
that we'll send you into counseling,
but buddies,
are you going to,
that's,
I think that's real.
Like they've had that conversation before.
Every time you get out of line,
hi Krista,
we're sending you back to counseling again,
but I liked that she did the poly technique,
but are you going,
are you going to,
that's the whole key.
You pursue shit.
You got a question.
You gotta push it?
69 69 70.
Yeah,
it's a good time.
It was good.
Um,
I had the clip pool that you asked me to pull from CNN.
This is hilarious.
This was in regard,
I think,
was this about the fires?
So that was going on here.
Oh my God.
No,
it's happened in Tampa,
sorry.
In Tampa.
Oh,
about the serial killer or an arrest because they had a serial killer there.
Um,
killed some people earlier this year.
Anyways,
there's a sign language person,
um,
that,
you know,
they,
they do for like big press conferences.
So this woman just came in and she's not a sign language interpreter and just
did it that
sign language interpreter accused of signing total
jibberish
the serial killings.
MMM.
We will be charging four counts of first degree murder is hilarious.
It's not to decide apparently translating every word this morning.
Okay.
Isn't that hilarious?
So she did it wrong.
She was,
I wasn't doing it all.
She's just like made it up just there having fun.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
5,000 tip five.
But it turns out
was nonsense.
She waved her arms around like she was singing jingle bells sign language
experts.
The woman identified as Durland Roberts has a string of a rent.
So how did she come to be translating at last week's high profile conference?
I just didn't ask enough questions.
Tampa police,
public information officer Steve Heggerty told me the woman's simply showed up
out of the blue and offered her services.
Yeah.
My immediate reaction like go,
I didn't call for a sign language interpreter,
but that's great that we have one here.
Right.
Let her in.
This woman appear to know what she was doing to the untrained eye and that would
include mine.
Um,
I didn't see any problems.
Hilarious.
Oh my God.
That's motivate somebody.
Is it a money?
He's been arrested.
She's like,
I'll fuck with the police.
Yeah,
she's got a sense of humor.
She got,
I'm a fuck with these motherfuckers.
Yeah,
this shit works.
The shit comes three months after it was revealed that the sign language
interpreter and then her current cane urban,
who is this guy,
bad guy.
It's
time to act is now.
And he was like,
no.
Coming up.
That woman again.
Oh really?
I say this was not a quote,
but it was an ethical violation.
Yeah,
that's the thing is they are,
they asked him,
I saw that in the news that day.
They're like,
there's nothing like there's no charge.
Yeah.
She just annoyed the shit out of everybody.
That's like I don't,
I can't hear the craziest her track her criminal record.
That's yeah,
she's legit and yeah,
she really is one that we like our house alarms going off hold on.
Or House alarmists yes.
She slammed the door too hard.
Oh,
who is she?
Oh Man.
Oh boy.
We can talk about her now when she leaned.
Now let's talk some shit.
Ambulance,
get those black penises up here.
Yeah,
man.
Um,
so what do you think about that?
Yeah.
Black decks.
I'll watch that shit.
Yeah.
That's crazy that your site,
is that your go to?
Yeah,
that's my go to.
Is it really?
Yeah.
Cause I'm in shock.
I can't believe it.
How,
what,
how,
how hard they give it to him.
That?
Well,
when I was growing up,
when you still watch pornos it was like a,
it was,
um,
it was like a taboo.
Interracial.
Yeah.
It was like a taboo and now it's like the opposite.
It's like a whole genre.
I mean,
it's like a popular one.
Yeah.
And I'm still freaking you out in a way.
And the anal sex,
it's like really bizarre too,
because again,
when I was growing up,
it was like a taboo to have sex in the butt.
And now like every single porno,
it's like,
it's like a taboo doubt,
sex in the vagina,
you know what I mean?
Sure.
It's like the vagina just sitting there just like,
you know,
board.
Yeah,
you're right.
You know what I mean?
It was like the first shot.
Now it's weird,
right?
Yeah,
I think so.
I Dunno.
It never got into so gnarly.
It wasn't into anal,
you know?
Oh yeah.
It is what it is.
It was the anal,
a big part of your,
you know,
sexual exploits.
There's been a couple of times,
but you always have to ask the girl.
Yeah,
well,
yeah.
You can't just like put it in.
No.
And do you always make sure you have lube on those moments or no?
You got to ask the girl.
Really?
Yeah.
Sometimes you can like,
like lick your finger and then put that in and that.
Sure.
It's Kinda like,
uh,
that's kind of like a,
a version of loop,
you know what I mean?
If you just like,
Yup.
And then,
well then you just put the,
you know what I mean?
We used to live in and he put the,
put the,
put it right in the rectum hall and then you'd do the passing the baton.
Why don't you do a sex show?
That's what I'm thinking.
Yeah.
Uh,
sex podcast,
you have to think you have credible.
Here's what works.
People talk about a topic within,
they have credibility,
you know,
everyone knows you got laid a lot.
Fucking talk about it.
Yeah.
You can give people tips.
Imagine you with like a kid.
Um,
he was like,
I'm going to college and nervous.
I don't know how to get laid and then fucking weasel comes in.
Shows them what's up.
I mean,
what would you tell some 19 year old kid listening right now?
He's like,
I don't,
I don't know how to,
how to approach girls.
What do you tell him?
I bet you have good advice.
I would,
um,
it depends.
I think it's a case by case.
That's depends on what the person looked like and what the vibe of the person
was.
Let's say they're just like
a little insecure and they a are a little overweight and they're,
you know,
they just,
uh,
they're just don't have any experience so they don't know what to do.
But there's cute girls walking around campus and they're like,
well I would definitely say the last thing.
Definitely try to make them laugh.
There you go.
I think that's important.
I'm trying to get Pauli talk cause he'll laugh on black penises.
You know,
if you see a black peanut,
you just laugh at it.
Yeah,
that's what he was saying.
I was saying that,
but he said he can give advice to guys who want to get laid,
you know,
like great idea.
That'd be a great podcast teaching dudes had to get where you guys can do the
show.
This show that's going to be on FX because Louise is not there anymore.
He could take that slot.
Right.
And then I can,
I can do my podcasts from here.
What's your neighborhood kids coming in here?
I can teach him how to get laid.
That's a great idea.
Just think about it.
Yeah.
I think laughing is the first and foremost,
you know disarming the Babes.
Yeah.
You gotta yeah you gotta disarm debate.
He was just saying like if he had a night,
if there's a 19 year old kid,
how,
and I said well it's a case by case like what does the kid look like?
And he's like,
cause his little chubby little insecure and I'm like we'll probably make the
girl laugh.
Something silly.
Girls always say that horse shit on their profiles.
They can make me laugh.
That's always number one.
I don't know if that's true,
but they say they do want to make,
I think the laughing thing is true.
You got to follow up.
You've got to go for the close.
Maybe they can also get a penis enlargement too,
so once,
because once a girl has a really nice penis and then usually she goes back to
it,
you know,
it's kind of like familiar territory
for you were the wheeze on MTV and I was the skis on VH one for you.
Getting laid is pretty well before that.
Yeah.
Good game.
The hair,
he had the full head of hair.
I don't know.
My Mom's side,
my mom on the comedy store too.
I'd be like,
Yo Babe,
come on.
Get you some Nachos.
Hey,
I'll get you a Shirley temple.
Were you there all the time.
Even as like as a teen because that's when it's even cooler.
I think it's like friends are like,
oh,
let's go drink at so and so's house.
But you can like walk into the store.
No,
I used to.
There used to be the comedy store Westwood.
Yeah.
You never went there.
I remember a time when they close it and like the 84 or something
existing may not have been there.
I remember existing.
Oh well yeah.
Okay.
Well then you remember it was right next to it was an arcade.
So we used to bring my friends there.
We still do whippets and watch you and watch all the M and watch my,
my girlfriend at grown named Leslie Zeeman from the valley.
She um,
went to Birmingham,
she was my prom,
my prom date and my girlfriend in high school.
And uh,
we still have sex
but sex probably she's from the valley,
you know,
they all do.
You Handle Valley Jewish valley babe
for that will be good.
You need to give millennials advice cause I do another podcast called that steep
brow and I get emails from 20 year olds like I don't know how to talk to people.
How do I talk to girls,
how do I make friends?
It's just,
you know,
it's different.
Like you give out free rent,
you know,
all of that was the thing.
They want to come over.
And
actually it's a great idea if you want to get laid,
put out a thing where people know that if they,
if they fuck you,
they could live in your house for free.
So it's an exchange of goods services.
You know it's a contract contract and in legal terms,
that's a really good way to get later.
If you're having trouble getting laid,
give away housing.
So who cooks?
Men from jail,
homeless or dog.
You want to come move in?
Frankenmuth cheer,
man.
Free Range.
At least in the case.
Fuck me.
Just in your home there.
Now you see me?
I come up with today and try it out.
Try it out,
man.
Try it out.
Try Out.
Since we don't cut,
I'll tell you.
I'll tell you the secret to our joy.
My occasionally I do,
but I know how to cook well.
Well we do.
We just,
it's you know,
and who's got the time.
But here's what we decided to do that saved our relationship.
Real talk.
Even when we didn't have the money hire to fucking housekeeper.
I'm talking,
Tommy and I were broke as a joke.
We still had the $30 a week or whatever to someone else,
clean up the boxers,
scrub those toilets on the weekend and she'll like that.
Yeah,
it just saves you the heartache.
Have you ever lived with a woman?
Like if you ever had a serious relationship?
Kinda Kinda,
yeah.
What's the longest this girl that had been with for awhile,
right.
This is the longest.
Probably.
How long is it?
Over five years.
Oh really?
That's nice.
He's like,
really?
Do you think it's really got,
I mean,
do you think you'll get married little weasels?
I don't know.
I'm very,
uh,
you know what I mean?
It's very hard for me.
I know.
Especially because you've been on your own for so long and you're,
yeah.
I like,
you know,
I kind of go back and forth with it,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
So,
you know,
hey,
that's a real,
it sounds like it's a real deep issue.
Do you ever see a therapist?
We ever done that?
Yeah.
You ever talk about that?
Well,
I've done group therapy.
Oh no one bro.
Get in there.
I don't know.
A good one.
Really.
I'll recommend you to really did a girl or a boy.
Well,
you wouldn't see my therapist.
That's a conflict of interest.
But yeah,
you can't have your friends and family saying,
oh,
female or male.
Probably a female I think makes more sense for me.
You have a more lady issues than issues with women than men.
Let's say.
I'm cool with everyone.
It's just as far as like you guys lived together,
like you have a baby like that's full on like jumping in the water.
Yeah.
Well that's my issue.
Full on.
Jumping in the water and it's like there's something I really like about coming
home and knowing no one is going to be there and know what,
what gives you the most with her?
It's not her at all.
It's me.
It's like,
I don't know.
It's just like,
because all day long I'm doing stuff just like you guys are and then you come
home.
Sometimes you just want to be by yourself.
Yeah.
You know,
but I guess,
you know,
you guys do that when you're on the road too.
Yeah,
we have a lot about wait times,
but do you think she might give you that space?
Like when you came home,
like give you an hour to yourself if you tore us.
Yeah,
of course.
But right now I'm staying in an apartment in silver lake,
so it's kind of,
it's a one bedroom apartment,
so that's not really conducive.
Right,
right.
Oh,
what do you mean?
It's like,
it's not like a big house.
Yeah,
I think it is scary to get married and it is scary to get this responsible.
It's the jumping in the water all the way.
Well,
cause I remember when Tom and I first got married,
there were times when I felt like I,
I had to run,
like if we fought or something,
I'd be like,
I gotta go,
I gotta head for the hills.
And I think that's like a childhood thing that I had to resolve in therapy.
Obviously I don't feel that way now,
Tommy.
Uh,
but it's a process,
you know,
I think it's a process.
It doesn't,
it's not normal if you're,
especially if you have someone all the time.
Well,
it's,
I think it's a growing process,
you know,
especially if you've got some stuff that needs to be resolved or whatever.
Okay.
That's my,
she says,
yeah,
I'd love for you to go to therapy and Tom as well.
Come on.
Let's talk about real quick before you go.
I know he's got to go to,
you've got to go down and go.
Yeah.
There's an email about kicking ass ripper.
Says a mommies.
I was revisiting the stripper catalog and had a thought.
My old roommate was lactose intolerant to such a degree that he got terrible gas
pains every time we drank milk.
How funny.
It's tied into the other thing.
The volume and consistency of these forts were similar.
They're not equal to the kings.
I believe this may be how the king is able to muster these mythical farts.
Josh,
you know about king ash ripper?
No.
Uh,
he's,
uh,
Internet sensation and he makes,
this is why I want to get out of the entertainment business for this type of,
she cause it because well,
you're like,
he's a celebrity on the thing.
Oh yeah,
I've been his ass.
I'm like,
yeah,
I can keep up with this stuff.
No,
I know.
That's,
that's just raw talent though.
You know what I mean?
What's he doing?
He's fine.
She loves it.
Just really tickles me.
It's absurd.
He does.
He goes to this for,
he does do a lot of
our social life and their prospects for getting weighed.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
I see.
I don't think it's funny at all,
but I think it's funny that you guys think it's,
I know that's hilarious
and like bet you guys have been putting this on your show.
It's funny to me for he
for eight,
but he's like a big,
he's into it.
He's really into it.
He also does a lot of glutton videos
were there.
Know I'm having a big ass fucking breakfast or for bean and cheese burritos
lathered with two big ass
fucking six sausage and cheese patties.
Aw,
look at that.
4 billion.
That's about 5 million.
1,000 calories each sausage patties.
He gets kicked off a lot of the platforms that he's on.
All right,
so then he'll,
he'll piss sneak around.
He'll sneak around.
So he'll be on live league and then you'll go back to youtube.
Then he's on just like a,
he bombs and he's back on line.
I fart in your face is one of his handles or Harry and gross.
But I think you should look him up.
He's really talented.
That's my favorite part of the whole day.
You doing that?
How are you can act in movies and create a persona y
man become a cultural phenomenon or you just heard on the Internet?
Not For me.
All right.
But I mean,
I appreciate it.
I'm happy that he's got so many views.
Yeah.
And you can donate.
If you want him to eat something for you on camera or Fart for you,
you'll take your donations.
Okay.
Yeah.
So look,
uh,
thank you first of all for coming over.
I know you've got to go to this game.
Um,
it was seriously fun to,
to hear the insight on a lot of this stuff,
man.
Seriously.
So you're likely to go the fuck away if you ever get hugely successful,
go away,
throw away thing.
So you gotta you gotta you know,
especially when your representatives and people around you and,
but I don't know.
I think that,
um,
you know,
we're,
you're lucky to catch fire on anything in this business.
You know,
you catch up,
catch a wave and if you get as big as I got,
you know,
like,
so like,
like this,
it's good to go away.
Yeah.
That's great advice.
Um,
you can see a bunch of polys videos on funny or die.
He's done it.
He's done a number of them.
Um,
and you can catch him on tour.
Do you have any upcoming,
like when is this going to air?
It comes out tomorrow,
man.
Oh Shit.
Okay.
I'll be at the saint Louis funny bone this weekend.
Oh Great.
Yes.
Saint Louis.
Funnybone.
Yeah,
it's a great,
it's actually the first funny bone.
Is it really the first one?
Yeah.
All right.
It smells like it too,
which is awesome.
Yeah.
Do they still smoke in there?
There's some clubs with,
yes.
I think they still,
sometimes they have like a smoking show.
They'd be like the early show.
They'll smoke and then I'm bringing Josh Martin with me.
He's great.
He's good.
Who Do you guys,
who opens for you guys when you don't,
you bring someone or you go by yourself sometimes bringing that full shrine.
Joe Barton,
Nick,
Jeff Tate abroad.
Josh Potter do a bunch of gigs this year.
He's from buffalo but lives here now.
Yeah.
Very funny.
And then there's other guys too.
I brought,
but like this year,
potter,
find your girl.
If I meet a girl and a fat unattractive unfuckable not like hi.
I'll say hi.
He's about to say,
wait,
wait til her mix.
I was like,
I got to fact check for it.
Yeah.
He's like,
I got some more for you.
All right girl.
That works at Oh,
she's great.
She's good.
I know what you're talking about.
She's really funny.
Her name is,
she's a big lesbian ground.
Yeah,
I see.
I see,
Okay.
Yeah,
we'll talk about her.
She's fantastic.
Okay.
Yeah.
Um,
thank you for coming today.
Thank you.
Um,
and uh,
also thank you guys for listening.
Of course.
Here's your song to go out,
lift
your jeans up higher.
Is this is this guy's going to fart on us.
I know.
I know Jason from Sacramento.
Thanks so much.
All right guys.
See you next time.
So
fucking
dry.
If you see my mouth,
don't mean to be
Zapchen starving.
Massive.
Now
with some steam keys,
just
g.